oh now you gotta run okay yeah that's
probably good for you too
all right
all right take that water bottle
if y'all want to sell water bottles
that's fine stay out of the streets
though because you got it
it's every all over when we're walking
you guys are y'all
just stay on the streets
just stay out of the streets that's all
i'm asking
i'm telling you right now they're
calling us i don't want to do something
about it right
i mean do you need me to do you want me
to write you a ticket for impeding
traffic
you're probably right you're probably i
probably should not
oh now you gotta run okay yeah that's
probably good for you too
keep it up
okay
okay
have a good day
have a good day
okay
well you're the one that said write you
a ticket now you don't want now you're
going to walk away
i can't even get it i'm a miner
you wanna you wanna do you really wanna
have a bet on that
i guarantee you stay out of the roadway
stay out of the roadway all right right
now you want to deal with it
out of the road
you two you're in the road come here put
your hands up
stop resisting you're gonna get tired
oh
get
back stop resisting
[Applause]
[Music]
get in the car get in the door
[Applause]
[Applause]
get out of the road
[Applause]
get out of the roadway get moving go
out of the roadway
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
put your hands behind your back
[Laughter]
containing
[Applause]
[Applause]
more investigation
[Applause]
what
on your back
[Music]
[Music]
hold on to her we got a full car here
stupid
who rolls around with it how are you
this is why would you roll around with
that
why
it was in the back we just selling water
crazy
okay
we got two that refused to get out of
the road it's gonna be obstruction
it's a bb gun
over there
[Music]
huh
yeah figure out her information
spread your legs
what's your first name
never been involved with the police at
all you're not going to pop them in my
system at all
okay you got a
did you ever get issue like a state id
or anything like that id card no okay i
can't get that job but i'm gonna go get
it okay no i'm just asking because it's
just gonna be easier to pull up the
picture in the system
this one no you can go over there we're
not dealing with it
big
[Music]
slide up a little bit and get these cars
in the line so we can get traffic moving
through here okay
we'll slide forward so we can get the
cars pulled into line
we're gonna slide forward so we get
these cars in the line
[Music]
yes for obstruction obstruction yep
follow along
i don't know if it's between you and the
judge
i told you guys multiple times
stop and listen god gave you two ears
and one mouth so you need to use no i
cannot talk to you absolutely once i'm
done explaining this i told you multiple
times stay out of the roadway as soon as
i got out of the roadway to detain you
to get your information which i'm
allowed to do all right so look you did
so i'm not i'm not done talking i'm not
done talking
so once i tried to get your information
you continuously tried to remove your
arms from my hands that is obstruction
you are trying to
because why is you touching me for it
because i told you guys multiple times
stay on the street
i can't get a hold of you because you're
a reminder right that's what i said then
i hop out on you now all of a sudden i'm
not in
female she said the glock was hurt or
the bag was hers i
didn't realize it was a bb gun at first
because it looks legit so
okay it's going to go with you all right
that's my money my phone my charging my
everything in there we got it right here
hey free me y'all
other side other windows open he's got
the ac game
[Music]
your other windows up and the ac is
rolling i'm not rolling this down so you
can yell back and forth
no you are and i'm not playing the games
okay
i told you it's pretty simple stay out
of the roadway
and instead of doing so
instead of doing so
look man there's no there's no talking
to you because you're just going to keep
talking over me so that's fine
so in doing so all you had to do was say
my bad i'll stay off the roadway you
guys could have stayed out here and did
you a little hustle
but you don't want to do that you want
to be disrespectful you want to keep
getting in the streets you want to throw
water bottles at people
so no i ain't playing the game no more
266